Tarantino can write a movie about
slavery where actually him and Jamie
they got the idea from me the idea for
Django I pitched to Jamie Foxx and
Quentin Tarantino as the video for gold
digger uh and then Tarantino turned into
a film okay well there's not truth to
the idea that Kanye West came up with
the idea of Django I had the idea for
Django for a while before I ever met
Kanye he wanted to do a giant movie
version of College Dropout the way he
did the album I mean Kanye we use it as
an excuse to meet each other he did have
an idea for a video and I do think it
was for the gold digger video that he
would be a slave and the whole thing was
the slave narrative where he's a slave
and he's singing gold digger it was very
funny it was yeah it was meant to be
ironic all right with him in this like
slave rag outfit all right doing
everything and then that was also part
to be part of the pushback on it and
look I wish he had done it it sounded
really cool anyway that's what he's
referring to